hi i'm doran rudov and i present the
talk on polynomially many queries to np
or qma oracles which is joint work with
lever caribbean at palabon university
note that i will explain basic quantum
computation later so in principle no
quantum background is required
first i go over the motivation for this
research and prior work
one may ask the question what lies
beyond np
stockmayer defines the polynomial
hierarchy which basically is the union
of complexity classes p e to the np p to
the np to the np and so forth
most relevant to our results is the
second level of ph delta 2p or p to the
np
generally we say p to the to p to the c
for the complexity class it can be
solved by a polynomial time turing
machine with access to an oracle for a c
complete
problem to gain an intuition note that
co-np is contained in p to the np
because the turing machine can perform
the corresponding np query and then
output the negated answer
we can define further complexity classes
by restricting the queries the turing
machine is allowed to perform
for instance we can restrict it to a
logarithmic number of oracle queries
the resulting complexity class is called
p to the np log and has the following
complete problem due to wagner
thus the solution to a max case that
instance have even hemming weight
to solve that with a logarithmic number
of
np-oracle queries first determine the
maximum number m of satisfiable clauses
using the binary search with oracle
queries of the form thus there exists an
assignment satisfying at least s clauses
then ask whether there exists an
assignment of even hemingway satisfying
m clauses
another kind of restriction is to
require the turing machine to ask all
oracle crays at the same time
hence the queries are non-adaptive they
cannot depend on each other
it has been shown that this class p to
the
denoted p to the parallel np is equal to
p to the np log which we'll also sketch
later in this talk
recall that p to the np generally
permits adaptive carries
so the ith query potentially depends on
the answers to all prior queries
we can model these dependencies as a dac
here qi is the ith query
in general this stack might be complete
in the case of non-adaptive carries
there are no edges between nodes
to construct
a connected query graph we add an output
node that simulates the turing machine
and returns its output
by placing restrictions on the query
graphs structure we can define
complexity classes between p to the np
and p to the parallel np and p to the np
godlob considers the restriction of
choreographs to trees and defines the
class trees of np of problems solvable
by a query tree and shows that this
class is equal to p to the np-log
in the quantum world we have the quantum
analog of np called qma quantum merlin
arthur which i'll define later
hitarev proves a quantum cook level
theorem by reducing qma to the k local
hamiltonian problem which i now describe
though its understanding is not integral
to the rest of the talk
we are given a hermitian matrix h of
dimension 2 to the n which is a sum of k
local terms h i
each acting on at most k qubits
except if the minimum eigenvalue lambda
min of h is below a
given threshold alpha
this is a relevant problem in physics as
h describes a quantum n-body system and
lambda min of h its ground state energy
all the energy of the system when cooled
to absolute zero
p to the q mail log also has a complete
problem called apx sim or approximate
simulation it was shown by unbinders
the problem is to perform measurements
on the ground state of a k local
hamiltonian
so here we are interested in properties
of the ground state itself rather than
its energy
a natural question is now whether the
results for p to the np log also have
analogues for p to the q mail log
caribbean pidoc and jirka show that p to
the q mail log is equal to p to the
parallel qma just like in the classical
setting
however it was previously not known
whether qma query trees can also be
solved with a logarithmic number of qma
queries
next i'll go over the results of our
work
we define cdeg as as the class of query
graphs of bounded separator number at
most s here we look at a constant
separator number s equals to o of one
separator number is a
graph parameter which is bounded by tree
width which i'll formally define later
paragraphs of bounded depth are called c
deck d again we consider a constant d
here
note that we use the term c deck to
either refer to instances of characters
or to the class of problems that can be
solved by such choreographs
now let's compare the new results with
previous state of the art
in the classical setting we have god
loop's result on query trees from 95.
we improve this to graphs of bounded
separator number or treatment
for qma we had the result that p to the
parallel qma is equal to p to the qma
log which we also extend to query graphs
of bounded depth and separator number
for a variety of complexity classes
one of the main challenges here was
dealing with the promise setting of qma
which is a class of promise problems
as a side note our techniques are
generally applicable to ma-like classes
however in the case of stochastic ma
which i also don't define here we can
only improve the previous result to
query graphs of bounded depth
and not bound to trivial because it is
not known whether the completeness the
soundness parameters of stockmate can be
amplified to a constant gap
more concretely our main result is for
these listed complexity classes here
a c deck of separator number s can be
decided with a deterministic turing
machine
in 2 to the s times log n time steps and
with s times log n c queries
bounding the separator number by a
constant we obtain the aforementioned
containment of c deck s
and p the z log
if we allow a poly logarithmic separator
number we get a quasi-polynomial time
base
and one extra log factor in the query
number
for chronographs of bounded depth we
obtain a very similar result with the
same time and query bounds
however we do achieve a polynomial time
base for np next and qma x
again bounding d by a constant we show
that c dash d is equal to p to this here
log
guitar f uses a circuit to hamiltonian
mapping in his quantum cook level
theorem to embed a quantum circuit
computation into a hamiltonian
the lifting lemma due to watson bausch
and caribbean then embeds non-adaptive
qma queries into apx-sim preserving
certain geometric properties of the
underlying circuit to hamiltonian
mapping such as locality
the idea behind these geometric
properties is to make the hamiltonian
more like a natural physical system
we extend this result to a generalized
lifting lemma in a simplified form there
exists a polynomial time menu run
reduction from choreographs of bounded
separator number or depth to apx sim
satisfying the geometric properties of
the circuit hamiltonian mapping hw
the main improvement over the previous
result is that we can now lift query
graphs directly and not just parallel
queries
now i will introduce some more formal
definitions
i would like to start with a brief
introduction to quantum computation
the state of n qubits is expressed by a
complex unit vector
cat psi this symbol here of dimension d
equals 2 to the n
the i
standard basis vector
is written cat i
and for a classical n bit string x we
write the corresponding standard basis
vector as k x
the hermitian transpose of a vector psi
is then written as broadside which is
the symbol here
quantum circuits apply unitary operators
on quantum states unitary means that
hermitian that the humision transpose of
u is equal to its inverse
generally we deal with k local operators
v which means that v
can be written as the tensor product
also known as chronic product of a k
qubit unitary u and an identity
here u then only acts on a subset of k
qubits
the reason for using local operators is
that they can be represented and
implemented efficiently
in quantum computation we can also
measure states which is modeled by a
povm positive operator valued measure
consisting of a set of positive
semi-definite matrices mi
that sum to identity
the probability of achieving outcome i
is then given by brabs i times m i times
cat
psi for example the probability of
getting a one when measuring the first
qubit standard basis is given by this
expression here where one one projects
the first qubit onto zero
as mentioned before the quantum analog
of np is qma
due to the probabilistic nature of
quantum mechanics qma is a class of
promise problems
problems are just like languages with
the addition of invalid query strings
that are neither yes nor no instances
a problem pi is in qma if there exists a
uniform polynomial times circuit family
qn such that for all
yes instances there exists a proof psi
such that qn accepts x together with the
proof with probability at most
two-thirds
and for no instances qn accepts with
probability at most one-third for all
proofs
note that this definition is just like
ma but with quantum circuits instead of
classical
the constants two-third and one-third
may also be replaced with thresholds
alpha and beta that
that the promise gap alpha minus beta is
at least an inverse polynomial
our results also hold for variants of
qma like quantum classical qma or qcma
where the proof psi is a classical bit
string
or qma2 where the verifier is given two
unentangled proofs we can also think in
terms of having two independent provers
now let's define what a qma query graph
is more formally in the rest of this
talk we mainly focus on qma but if you
are not quite comfortable with that you
can also drop the queue and assume a
classical
ama each node in the dac contains a qma
verifier qi
each qi receives as input a string zi of
the outputs from incoming edges
for example q3
receives x1 and x2 as that 3.
qi also receives a quantum proof psi i
the verifiers implicitly define promise
problems pi i in qma determining the
output x i
so if x i is equal
so we set x i
to 1 if that is a yes instance to 0 if
it's in no instance
or
if that i is an invalid instance then
x i can be either one or zero
non-deterministically
hence there can be multiple correct
query strings x but if x is a valid yes
instance or no instance of a query graph
then its output must always be 1 in the
yes case or 0 in the no case
recall that god loop shows that trees of
np is equal to p to the np log
we want to prove a similar result for
more general graphs
here the parameter that comes to mind is
bounded tree world as such graphs are
almost trees in some sense
in fact we use a slightly more general
parameter which is called the separator
number
the separator number s of g
is defined as the minimum s
such that every sub graph of g has a
balanced separator of size at most s
by balanced we mean that after removing
the separator each connected component
contains at most a constant fraction of
the remaining nodes
one can show that the separator number
is bounded by tree width which in turn
is bounded by log n times the separator
number
however we do not know if these bonds
are tight
if a graph has separator number s then
we can recursively decompose the graph
into a separator tree in which nodes are
separators of the subgraphs induced by
its descendants
on the right side you can see an example
query graph
its output node is y2
the separator tree is indicated by the
dashed lines
for example u1 and u2 form a balanced
separator
note that the edges here do not
necessarily have to follow the tree
structure so an edge from x2 to u2 would
also be allowed
next i will sketch the proof that qma
graphs of bounded separator number are p
to the qma log complete
to illustrate the basic approach i begin
with proving the simpler result p to the
np log is equal to p to the parallel np
in general p to the c log is contained
in p to the parallel c
suppose there are k adaptive oracle
queries then there are two to the k
different computation path in total
for logarithmic k we can then
pre-compute all these computation paths
in polynomial time non-adaptively
the other direction is slightly more
involved we need to simulate the
non-adaptive queries q1 to qn with a
logarithmic number of adaptive queries
suppose we are given proofs y1 to yn
define the query string x with each x i
is the output of running the verifier
corresponding to q i with proof y i
we say x is a correct query string if it
encodes the correct answers to all
queries
for np the unique query string of
maximum hemming weight must be correct
because then all queries for which there
exists an accepting proof are satisfied
we can compute the maximum hemming
weight using simple binary search
and we use a similar approach for other
complexity classes like qma but there we
have to deal with invalid queries and
probabilities
another important technique is
flattening trees which godlob uses to
prove
that trees of np is equal to p to the np
log
for reasons discussed later graphs with
long paths are hard to deal with for
example if we have a chain of queries
uvw then we can transform this chain by
creating two copies v0
and v1 of v in which the input from w is
hard coded with a constant 0 or 1.
then a node u prime is created from u
that selects the copy of v depending on
w's output for example if
if w outputs 0 then
u prime uses
v0 as v
now let's get to the p to the q a log
completeness proof for qma dx of bounded
separator number
the first direction is easy again as p
to the apparel qma computations can
trivially be modeled as a query tree as
seen in the beginning of the stock with
a separator number of one
to show the other direction we need to
construct a p to the q my log machine
evaluating a cherry graph g of bounded
separator number
the first step is to define a weighting
function for query graphs to prioritize
important queries for parallel and peak
queries it was sufficient to maximize
the hemming weight of the query string
but in a graph we need to give more
weight to nodes with more descendants
given a query string g we compress it
into an equivalent g prime such that
rates are polynomially bounded
permitting us to perform efficient
binary search
then we define the total solution weight
function assigning away to a set of
query proofs and outcomes this
corresponds to the query string's
hemming weight in the previous example
we show that qma queries can approximate
the maximum value of this function and
that only the correct query string
maximizes it
finally we compute the maximum weight
with a logarithmic number of qma queries
using binary search and then a query
string x of that weight
the final result is when the output
node's output xn
we use the same basic proof structure as
godlob in histories of np proof but with
a novel graph transformation and total
solution rate function adapted to
probabilistic promise classes
following this roadmap we begin by
defining the admissible weighting
function
we say a function f
mapping from the nodes v of a character
of g
to the real numbers
is c admissible if for all nodes v f of
v is at least one plus c times the sum
of weights of all outgoing neighbors of
w
so we can see that the weight on v
exceeds the weight on the neighbors
times c plus one
this definition is the same as godlobs
but with an added vector of g lc
for example the weighting function omega
of v defined as 2 to the c to the v up
arrow is c admissible where where v up
arrow denotes the set of nodes reachable
from v and g so nodes with more
descendants get a higher weight
effect an exponentially higher weight
if every node only has a logarithmic
number of descendants then omega is
polynomially bounded
unfortunately there exists graphs for
which any admissible weighting function
is exponentially large for example a
simple pathway
therefore the next step is to transform
the graph to bound the number of
descendants logarithmically
here we have the familiar example again
the basic approach is to create copies
of every node conditioned on nodes above
and in the same separator similar to the
previous example from godlok
an output node t is also added but we
can ignore this for now
for the node x1 which is here we create
copies
x1 to the z1 z2 z3 conditioned on
outputs z1 z2 d3
of u1 u2 v1 v2 x1 and x2
each that i corresponds here to the
outputs of nodes in one separator so for
example z1 denotes the outputs u1 u2
and for example we can see how x1
is only conditioned on the outcomes of
outputs of nodes that are in separators
above or in the same
separator in the separator tree
it may seem odd to condition a
computation on its own outcome but that
is only to simplify the construction
every copy only has outgoing edges to
nodes above it or in the in the
separator tree
therefore v up error is bounded by s
times d equals o of log n
in the case of a balanced separator tree
of constant separator size
hence the weighting function omega is
also polynomially bounded
copies in the separator tree need to
determine which copies of the inputs to
choose for example u1 depends on x2
therefore the copy
you want the z1 of u1 as to compute the
correct values the two uh
and that three conditioned on that one
to determine which copy
of x2 to the that one that to the three
to choose
similarly the output node now computes
the correct values that runs at two the
three
to choose the correct copy of the output
node y2
so we have created multiple copies of
each node which leads to an
inconsistency problem
this is no issue with languages such as
np because every node either outputs one
or zero deterministically but promise
problems can cause some problem here
in this example we have one invalid
query at the bottom followed by two
queries that act as identities passing
their input to the output and an xor as
output node
clearly the output node is always zero
regardless of the invalid query's output
however if we create two copies of the
invalid query both may have a different
output
in which case the xor would output a one
the solution is to merge redundant
copies
such that only one copy is used in an
actual computation
so this is our merged query graph
for example since x2 only depends on
x1 and v1 we merge all copies differing
in other bits in the conditioning string
this is indicated by these asterisks
here so only two bits remain in the
conditioning string all other copies are
merged
next we define
the total solution rate function
recall that this function is needed to
enforce all queries in the graph to be
answered correctly
given a query string x and proves psi1
to say n define
the total solution weight as the sum of
all queries with the weight f of vi here
times this expression
called gi
for x i equals 1
g i outputs the acceptance probability
of q i on input that i which is
implicitly defined a substring of the
query string x
and the proof psi i
if x i is equal to zero then gi just
outputs a constant gamma which is the
average of the completeness soundness
thresholds alpha and beta
the intuition behind gi is that it
penalizes an incorrect x i
if that is a yes instance but we have a
zero as x i then we have the value g i
here is equal to gamma which is smaller
than gi
in the yes case
where we have a one here which could be
at least either for the correct proof
if that is no is a no instance
then gi with a one gives us at most beta
which is smaller than gamma for oil
proofs
and we can see that the penalty for a
wrong x i is not delta
which is half of the promise gap
finally we define t as the maximum value
of a capital t as maximum value of t
over all query strings and proofs
next we show that we can approximate t
with qma queries
formally define the promise problem pi
deciding whether t is larger than s or
smaller than s minus epsilon
for a total weight w
for a polynomial total weight w and an
inverse polynomial epsilon
pi is contained in qma
and the proof we construct the verifier
v
with proof space x y1 to yn
corresponding to query string and proofs
v first measures x in standard basis to
obtain a classical query string x
then it selects i with probability p i
proportional to the weight on v i
if x i is equal to 1 it simulates the
circuit ui with input zi and proof
register yi
as it outputs 1 with relty gamma
and can now show that the maximum
acceptance probability of v of all
proofs is precisely equal to t over w
the next step is to show that the
maximum weight does indeed imply a
correct query string
formerly we show that if t of x plus 1
to psi n exceeds t minus delta
then x
must be a correct query string
if f is 1 over delta admissible
now suppose that x i is incorrect
let x i prime be the fixed value
and choose
psi prime to maximize the difference
between gi of x i prime and gi of x i
as seen previously by fixing x i we can
increase gi by at least delta
however changing x i may decrease gj of
neighbor's vj of vi
due to the definition of the admissible
weighting function we know that f of v i
times delta
exceeds the sum of weights on its
outgoing neighbors
v vj by at least delta
finally we compute the maximum weight
with a logarithmic number of q macros
using binary surge and then a query
string x of that weight the final result
is then the output nodes output xn
the generalization to other complexity
classes is straightforward
however for stochastic ma this is not so
easy because we did have to use the fact
that qma can be amplified which is not
known for stockmay
next i will show the basic construction
of the generalized lifting lemma
first we need to define the approximate
simulation problem or ap exim
given a k local hamiltonian h and
observable a numbers alpha beta epsilon
such that beta minus alpha and epsilon
at least inverse polynomial
in the s case there exists a ground
state psi of h such that psi has energy
at most alpha with regard to a
in the now case oil psi of energy at
most lambda plus epsilon so lambda is
the minimum eigenvalue of h here
f energy at least beta with regard to a
to restate the generalized lifting lemma
we want to construct a many one
reduction
from c deck s a c deck g a d
to a p x sim for constants d and s using
the given circuit to hamiltonian mapping
hw and preserving its geometric
properties
to construct the apx-sim instance recall
the verifier computing t it first
selects i with probability p i
then if x is equal to 1 it simulates a
circuit q i and otherwise it outputs 1
with probability gamma
in this diagram we denote this output by
q flag or the flag qubit xn here is
simply the last bit of the query string
corresponding to the output of the
character
the ground state of
the hamiltonian from the circuit to
hamiltonian construction h w of v
is simply the history stage phi
which is a superposition of intermediate
states in the computation of v here each
vi is one gate of v
we define the apx sum instance with a
hamiltonian h is equal to alpha
times h w of e plus the projector of q
flag onto 0 times the projection of the
last time step of the computation i for
here is some suitably chosen constant
which i'm not going to detail
the observable a just projects xn onto
0.
the ground state of age is then the
history state with initial state v 0 so
this corresponds to that one
where v 0 then contains the parameters
maximizing t
here hw ensures that the ground state of
age is indeed a history state of this
form
and projecting the flag qubit onto 0
ensures
that the ground set here maximizes t
a then can check whether the computation
is accepting or rejecting
to conclude the talk we discuss some
open problems
can we extend
our results to further classes such as
qma1 with perfect acceptance probability
or uqma with a unique accepting proof a
stochastic ma where we're not able to
show all our
results what is the exact relationship
between separate and number entry with
can separator number ever exceed
separator number can tribrid ever exceed
separator number by more than a constant
factor
can we compute separator trees or
approximate separated trees more
efficiently
because for a bounded separator number a
simple brute force approach is
sufficient
however there also exists graphs with a
constant size separator tree but a
logarithmic separator number in that
case we don't know how to compute the
separate tree efficiently
lastly we show that for poly logarithmic
separator number t s is contained in
qp or quasi polynomial time with poly
logarithmic
c queries
is the quasi polynomial time base really
necessary here
and thank you for listening feel free to
send any questions to my email